التحدي في وجه الملاحقات القضائيه ويمضي
قدما في طريق البحث عن العوده الى كرسي
الرئاسه الرئيس الامريكي السابق ينظم اول
تجمع انتخابي لها منذ ان اعلن رسميا ترشحه
شهرا نوفمبر الماضي والاختيار وقع على
مدينه ويكو في ولايه تكساس اختيار ويكو
يحمل دلالات متعدده سيما في هذا التوقيت
الحساس جدا بالنسبه لرئيس الامريكي السابق
الذي يواجه تهما قضائيه مختلفه اخرها تهمه
دفع اموال للممثله الاباحيه
مقابل سكوتها عن علاقه غراميه بينهما
مدينه ويكو شهدت منذ 30 عاما هجوما مميتا
على طائفه معارضه للسلطه الفيدراليه ما
جعلها تشتهر بمناهضه الحكومه وهذه هي
رساله الاولى التي يرغب ترامب في ايصالها
وهي حشد المناهضين للسلطه الفيدراليه وهو
ما اعرب عنه بشكل صريح حين حذر من موت
ثمار محتملين اذا اصبح اول رئيس سابق في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده يواجه اتهامات
جنائيه معطى اخر يفسر هذا الاختيار وهو ان
تكساس بشكل عام تعد معقلا جمهوريا بامتياز
وما يؤكد ذلك عدم نجاح اي مرشح ديمقراطي
في الفوز على مستوى الولايه منذ عام
1994 دون ان ننسى ان تعد ارضا خصبه
للحركات السياسيه اليمينيه المتطرفه وتضم
جيوبا كبيره من المحافظين الدينيين وهم
جزء كبير من قاعده ترامب السياسيه
[تصفيق]
والاكيد ان تجمع ويكو سيشكل فرصه كبيره
للتراب لاظهار شعبيته المستمره لدى
القاعده الجمهوريه وتصوير نفسه مره اخرى
على انه ضحيه تامر سياسي من الحكومه
الفيدراليه وسام الذهبي العربيه